luffy and shanks are about to meet very
soon and for a good reason it is
probably the most anticipated event in
all of one piece right after finding
roger's treasure by itself luffy and
shanks will clash in a race for reaching
love tale and the straw hat will be at
the center of it all some people will
tell you that this will never happen
either because shanks will be taken out
by blackbeard or because he has been the
main villain of the story secretly all
along or simply because oda sensei wants
to subvert our expectations well i call
bs because when you really follow the
breadcrumbs that oda sensei has
sprinkled throughout the story i think
it's impossible to come to any other
conclusion than that shanks and luffy
will have to meet and not in a friendly
handshake well done becoming a yonko let
me now tell you a few secrets about the
world sort of way luffy and shanks will
clash in fact all of the straw hats will
have to face the terrifying powers of
the red hair pirates and each and every
one of them will have to surpass their
current level to emerge victorious and
all of it will have been according to
shanks's plan you see the closer we are
to the end of the story the more obvious
it has become that shanks has been
somewhat of a secret mastermind that has
been pulling the strings behind the
scenes guiding luffy towards becoming
pirate king and reaching love tail i
think what we all tend to overlook is
that shanks is really special and not
just because he is a yonko now he always
has been reeling shanks's straw hat that
is luffy's personal treasure now as we
know has been passed down from the
former pirate king goldie roger himself
now this could have of course just been
a random piece of clothing with just
emotional value to luffy until we see
this giant frozen straw hat on marijuana
that emo is looking at right here
whether or not it is the actual national
treasure of marijuana or not the straw
hat has a special meaning in this world
it's something the secret ruler of the
world keeps hidden and very close to
himself and while i would really love to
know who inherited the head to roger in
the first place what is much more
important for us right now is that
shanks has always been wearing this hat
ever since he was a cabin boy on roger's
ship the hat is special and roger passed
it onto shanks when he was just a kid
presumably when he was around luffy's
age where he got the hat from shanks so
there was something about shanks that
stood out to roger and made him pass on
that hat and his will to shanks instead
of say buggy or his first mate rayleigh
what exactly is special about him we
don't know yet maybe shanks is actually
a celestial dragon maybe he's the son of
roxy sebeck almost everyone is
speculated at this point or maybe as i'd
like to personally think it will be
something even bigger and more
mind-blowing than both of these things
the point here is that shanks always had
roger's trust and a special place in his
crew as we now know everything changed
for the roger pirates once they found
the one piece and learned the true
history of the world roger knew that he
was way too early to change and liberate
the world presumably because the return
of joy boy and the birth of the ancient
weapons was yet to happen however roger
also knew that he could play the
decisive role of making sure joyboy
would actually return and ease his way
remember joyboy and the ancient kingdom
already lost to the world government
once before so just because luffy is joy
boy doesn't automatically mean that he
will win luffy could have died or turned
evil or never had gotten his devil fruit
in the first place and so roger really
tried his best to make sure that joyboy
is born and help him awaken and reach
love tale only that he was about to pass
away from his mysterious illness so what
did he do he fathered ace declared the
great era of piracy to inspire as many
people as possible to look for lovetail
and go against the world government and
then instructed a few trusted members of
his crew with finding and then guiding
joy boy as a result crocus waited at the
entrance of the grand line for the right
person to come while rayleigh was
stationed at the entrance to the new
world and as we know both rayleigh and
crocus called luffy the man roger had
been waiting for and while crocus
pointed the crew in the right direction
and told them about left tail rayleigh
actually protected luffy trained him and
then prevented him from losing his will
after ace's death but by far the most
important role of all fell to the man
that roger had inherited his straw hat
to shanks was the one who tracked down
the legendary nikanika fruit joyboy's
devil fruit that had been escaping the
world government's hands for centuries
and that had been erased from the
history books only that shanks and roger
of course probably learned about its
true nature on love tale the last island
on the grand line that contains gold
silver the true history of the world and
this magic subscribe button please press
it so i can reach 1 million and make my
parents proud of me
and so carrying this most important of
devil fruits with him shanks went around
looking for the right person to eat it
and become joy boy my personal guess is
that shanks came to the east blue and
dawn island looking for ace roger's son
expecting him to eat the fruit but as we
all know the nika fruit chose luffy
instead and so shanks made sure to do
everything in his power to prime luffy
for success and have him awaken joy boy
and become pirate king first he passed
on roger's head to luffy the torch
carrying the flame capable of changing
the world and he sacrificed his arm to
ensure that luffy would keep his promise
to become a great pirate he then spent
the years chasing after blackbeard who
with his devil fruit most likely is the
biggest threat to luffy and joy boy
succeeding he stopped the war most
likely because luffy was there stopping
kaido from coming there who was also on
a mission to try and awaken joy boy but
most importantly he has been waiting for
luffy to become strong enough to finally
face him and return the straw hats
carrying the promise to become a great
pirate like shanks and this meeting has
been foreshadowed and addressed
throughout the story multiple times by
shanks himself he doesn't want luffy to
see him during marine fort and after the
events of whole cake island he comments
that their meeting is going to happen
very soon so i really think that the
argument that shanks might pass away
before the meeting happens doesn't make
sense especially after the latest
chapter yes oda could still somehow
subvert our expectations here but
subverting expectations for the sake of
subverting expectations makes no
freaking sense i think luffy strawhat is
his treasure he wants to become pirate
king because of shanks luffy will only
accept that he's become a great pirate
once shanks says so not because the
newspaper calls him a yonko in other
words luffy needs closure with shanks
before he can even start becoming pirate
king and so i think there is really no
doubt anymore that this meeting will
most likely happen very very soon wano
is over luffy has defeated the strongest
creature in the world and has reached
the same level as shanks at least in
title shanks has already declared the
race for the one piece and not only that
but he also has awakened his devil fruit
and we have learned that shang stole
this legendary food from the world
government and shanks is now on the move
joining the race to love tale the most
likely scenario is that this could lead
into elbaf which has been foreshadowed
to be both shanks's arc and the next
destination for the straw hats after
wano and as i explained in this video
there is a really high probability that
the last road poneglyph is on the island
of the giants with shanks and so the
yonko will have a lot more to reveal to
us and luffy about his real plan what he
knows about lovetail and what he knows
about luffy's true role in the great
scheme of things remember now that the
yonko saga is over that has been from
fishman island all the way to wano
centering around kaido and big mom we
are now in the final saga the one piece
saga and that means that all of the four
current emperors will have to play a
role surrounding love tale and fighting
for the one piece luffy buggy blackbeard
and shanks all these characters that
have been shrouded in so much mystery
will now finally take the stage and
reveal who they really are and what they
really want so luffy will meet shang
soon and i think there will be a battle
as i think we've established by now
shanks is not the jolly careless pirate
that we meet in chapter one of one piece
but a calculated cold wire puller that
has tried to orchestrate the fate of the
world for the last 20 years and prepared
luffy's arrival on love tale and so
shanks will not just give luffy a high
five good job making it here and give
him the last pony glyph when they meet
before luffy can actually give his hat
back and complete his promise he will
test luffy and see if he is actually
worthy now this could very well be in
the form of an actual battle and fight
however since i still don't think that
shanks is a bad guy or that he would
risk killing luffy
that's not very likely i think luckily
oda sensei has prepared for exactly this
scenario to happen and it's the only arc
in one piece i am genuinely not a fan of
the davy backfight the reason i really
don't like this arc is simply because
foxxy as a character is annoying and the
mini games the two crews play are fairly
underwhelming however multiple
characters including sanji and robin
explain to us that the davey backfight
is very much a real thing that has been
taken very seriously by actual pirates
now offense foxy the common belief that
the island where this took place could
have been beehive island and that the
davey backfight was how rox assembled
his powerful crew but one way or another
it is the perfect chance for the redhead
pirates to test the straw hat crew and
it of course would be a much more
serious and extreme version of what we
saw with foxy it could actually mean
testing zorro's sword skills to the
extreme seeing how good usopp can snipe
and how strong luffy's conqueror's
hockey is compared to shanks in other
words it's perfect this way luffy and
coke can show how much they have grown
and prove themselves as worthy luffy can
finally return his head to shanks only
is luffy really luffy and the straw hats
really the straw hats without well the
iconic straw hats well luckily enough
the davey backfight has the perfect
answer to this problem as well usually
the winner of a davey backfight can
choose a member of the other crew to
join his ranks however as we saw with
foxy objects are also accepted if the
jolly roger counts as a replacement
surely a straw hat would count as well
and anyways luffy wouldn't actually take
one of shanks's members by force anyway
but even then i think there's a legit
chance that shanks might accompany luffy
to love tail as we know he and buggy
have never actually been to the last
island since buggy fell sick and shanks
decided to stay behind with him and so i
think it would just be perfect for the
story for all four yonko together on the
last island and there compete for the
title of pirate king and it would also
give us a few chapters of luffy and
shanks interacting which really is all i
want and after all shanks to 99.99
has the last wrote poneglyph as well if
you want to know why you really can't
miss out on this video right here